hey everybody how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel so
I realized the other day it's been like
an entire year since I published my
office tour video and I thought it was
time for like an upgrade an update on
you all about my current desk setup
because if you haven't heard I have been
in the depths of like software
engineering land I went back to work as
a software engineer so my desk setup is
looking a little bit different these
days over the years it's been through a
lot of different versions and
Transformations and I feel like each
version really kind of spoke to the
season of life that I was in depending
on what I was doing how I was spending
my days what I was doing at my desk and
also how much resources I had and since
I'm in this new season of life right now
and my life right now looks different
from my life last year I figured I'd
make a desk update video and also
because I really like making these kinds
of videos alright so let's get into it
and first I want to talk about how
because I spend my days mostly as a
software engineer now my needs are
different from my desk so the first
thing that I wanted to focus on was I'm
going to focus on developer ergonomics I
spent spend a lot of time at this desk
mainly coding so whatever I can do to
make it really comfortable and easy to
code is kind of how I'm going to
structure and make decisions about what
to put on my desk it's definitely less
about audio visual than it was last year
too because I'm not doing as much
filming I'm not doing as much content
creation at my desk like there's not
really any of that that's a big part
that has really changed the other thing
that I can think of is that my needs are
less creative and more kind of like
building execution oriented I say that
because while I know that coding can be
creative and stuff to me it's a very
different type of creative of making
like videos versus building something
with code and the last piece is that it
needs to be more comfortable I'm gonna
be spending more time at my desk because
most of the work that happens for
software engineer is on a computer
versus content creation you're filming
you might be out and about vlogging and
stuff somewhere anyway I spend more time
on my desk now so those needs have kind
of evolved into three principles that I
had for Designing my desk setup the
first is that it's really easy to focus
this on the task at hand so I can really
just zoom in zero distractions and work
the second thing is that it needs to be
dependable and reliable I don't want to
be repairing things I just want to sit
down and know that everything is going
to work and it hasn't changed since
yesterday and the third thing is that I
needed to be comfortable but also
flexible so that I'm not super rigid and
I can kind of move around with my desk
if I needed to so the first part of my
desk setup that I wanted to talk about
is the desk itself and this one I'm
really excited to talk about because I
did a major upgrade to my desk this is
the erkin office suede desk in White Oak
with a white base and the size that I
got is 30 by 60. ergon office is
actually the sponsor of today's video so
thank you to ergon office for sponsoring
and ergon office is a company that was
founded in 2014 based in Montreal Canada
and there are B Corp certified which I
thought is super duper cool because I've
never heard of an office like setup
company that has that certification
which I always think is really cool to
have I really really really like this
desk I've been using for about two weeks
now every day on the job and oh my gosh
it is just like the most beautiful and
elegant desk that I've ever seen so the
sway standing desk uses locally sourced
solid wood and is hand crafted in
Montreal and it's just so pretty the
wood grain is a really nice tone and
really beautifully done it's finished
really nicely too so like me putting
something that's a little bit wet on the
desktop is not going to create a ring on
it it's actually really forgiving like
if I put snacks or if I drop something
on it like it hasn't chipped or anything
like that so it's very sturdy another
part that I want to talk about in terms
of sturdiness is that if you lean on it
it doesn't Bend at all which is like
really nice because sometimes I still
come to my room with me and he likes
it's really nice to know that dust is
not would you be with him small detail
but it really counts in order to operate
the dust going from standing to sitting
they've got a unique swipe technology
where you can swipe up or down to go to
a pre-saved height it's got a little
tiny screen on the top and the haptic
feedback I tell you like I could just
like play with the touchpad all day
because it's just so so like it's a
delightful product truly and then of
course I really needed the kind of
sitting and standing mode because I need
to be able to kind of switch between the
two just change it up so I'm not just
sitting for like eight hours a day
another thing that's really cool about
this desk is that up to four users can
have their own settings so you can have
this in like a shared space or if you or
your partner or your roommate want to
use one desk but like be able to have
your own settings like this is a really
good one urban office is actually having
a summer sale where for the whole month
of June they have up to 20 off site-wide
you don't need any promo code and the
discount is already applied onto your
website and so go check it out the next
item that I want to talk about is this
desk shelf which is also from urban
office this also uses locally sourced
solid wood which I got it in White Oak
to match the desk it's very minimalistic
and it kind of creates a really nice
like way to organize the things on my
desk without it looking more cluttered
this is my first time having a desk
shelf and I gotta say it's really nice
because it creates like an extra layer
for you to like put stuff on top of so I
have my like MacBooks on one level my
speakers on another like anything that I
need to have like right below my monitor
I'm like a little clock right there to
just keep an eye on the time the next
part of my desk setup that I wanted to
talk about was my chair this is also
from ergon office and this is the
YouTube chair I got it in small and this
really beautiful like white and kind of
taupe color that I feel like matches the
aesthetic of my whole office in terms of
how I feel about it hands down I think
this is actually like the most
comfortable office chair that I've ever
sat in truly because this is like my
third office chair I've also sat in
office chairs at offices that are from
like really like popular well-known
brands with this one I feel like is
actually more comfortable I like it more
it has all the bells and whistles that
you would expect from an office chair of
being able to customize basically every
single part of the chair to your liking
and what I really like about is the seat
itself is a good balance of firm and
soft and because of the sea and also all
the customizations that you can do in
the actual chair itself I've notice that
my body is just less tired at the end of
the day after sitting in it for a long
period which I feel like that's the
thing if you sit in a chair that doesn't
get you tired you know it's a good chair
one thing that's really cool about this
YouTube chair is that they recently
released one for like smaller people AKA
anybody who is less than five four which
is me what that means is that the seat
can go lower and more parts of the seat
are customizable to fit your body size
moving on to the next part of my desk
setup I want to talk about the computer
that I use for work I have have the 2022
MacBook Pro with the M1 chip now this is
probably like the de facto computer that
companies are handing out to software
Engineers these days so it's nothing
unique or special really about it but I
did want to comment about the M1 chip
and how great it's been for my work
currently I've been developing all in
Swift UI and one of the great Parts
about Swift UI is that you can render
what your view is going to look like on
the screen without needing to build and
compile your app and I've noticed that
if I run that to like do that on my
Intel chip computer
it's not responsive my computer heats up
and sometimes actually just straight up
crashes but on the M1 like seamless just
in general it's very responsive like it
never has the fan turn on so I know that
we're all on board with the M1 chip
these days but I just want to say it as
a plus one doing iOS Dev every single
day and really kind of put my computer
through the ringer in that way good
laptop next up let's talk about my
monitor this is the LG 34 inch 2110 an
ultra wide QHD monitor with Ergo stand
now this is a part of my desk setup that
I've covered before I've continued to
use the ultrawide monitor I actually
have an entire video about how I feel
about this Monitor and the tldr is that
I love it it turns out it's a really
great monitor for Content creation but
it's also a really great monitor for
software engineering too and let me tell
you my favorite Parts I really love how
flexible it is and that you can raise it
lower it you can tilt it you can change
it in different directions like there's
so many customizations you can do in
terms of the positioning of the monitor
that I don't see in other like monitor
stands that comes with it and the other
part that I really really love about
this monitor is that I plug in all of my
peripherals into the monitor so that I
only need to plug one thing into my
computer and then I can use my keyboard
my web camera my speakers like all of
these things just turn on and I only
have to plug in one thing into my
computer like it's so dang good oh and
it charges my computer too which is like
big bonus and the other thing that's
really great about this monitor is the
stand itself has some built-in cord
management so you can hide all the cords
from your peripherals for the monitor
itself for your laptop just all hidden
away and extremely elegant as for the
form factor itself of it being Ultra
wide it's been really nice because it's
easy to have multiple screens open at
once in one seamless experience so
oftentimes I'll have xcode my coding IDE
on one side and like Chrome on the other
or I'll do like two-thirds and
one-thirds and the fact that a seamless
allows me to kind of change where that
like Gap is or like how big each one is
or how much space I want each one to
take versus having like two separate
monitors or three separate monitors
where there is like bevels that I need
to work with and because I'm staring at
this monitor like so dang much every
single day it's really nice that I can
adjust the colors and the brightness so
that my eyes don't hurt and the way that
I can tell is that my eyes don't hurt at
the end of the day similar to a chair if
your body just doesn't hurt by using it
for like many many hours a day it's
probably a good thing next up let's talk
about the keyboard and mouse so the
keyboard I use the keychron q1 and my
mouse I use my beloved MX Master 3s
these two I've covered in previous
videos and it just goes to show that
like these are really good tools I love
using them over and over and over again
for many many years the keyboard is
really just delightful to use I feel
like the Aesthetics really work with my
desk the keys are like a perfect amount
of clacky like clacky but not too loud
and it's just fun to type on which I'm
typing all day so this might as well
make it fun and then the mouse I feel
like I've talked about the MX Master
Series for five years on my channel and
it's still just it's still so good it's
really comfortable it's really quiet my
hand doesn't hurt at the end of the day
the only thing that I will say is that
the white color or like the gray color
is really nice but it does get kind of
dirty or often so I do have to clean it
the major selling point of the MX Master
is definitely the fact that you can
customize all the different buttons and
keys on it to your liking whether you
want it at like a system level or at an
app level and this is like a really
Minor Detail but one of the things I
really like about it is that one of the
buttons I have programmed to mute myself
on Zoom which when I can't find the dang
bar at the bottom when I'm gonna call
just being able to press the same button
every single time on my mouse to mute
myself or unmute myself just so nice
I need a desk setup video unless we talk
a little bit about stationery and you
know I've got to talk about this
notebook although I guess it's less of a
notebook and more of like a notepad
either way I got this from Muji so I
wanted something that was like kind of
like a legal Pad but smaller because I
don't necessarily need to save all the
notes that I'm writing in like a proper
bounded notebook and I just wanted to be
able to like write stuff down jot things
down and then be able to like put it
away get rid of it whatever I wanted to
do and so I was on the market for one
found one for Muji this one is so cute
and so nice and so functional so I
really think this is like the best
balance between Form and Function like
by having this notepad I'm not really
precious about the pages of just like it
was really easy for me to get started in
writing versus you know with notebooks
it's just like oh my God it has to be
super organized super clear I have to
follow that system forever and ever and
ever I can't break from it even though I
don't need to use it anymore in that way
oh very functional and then the thing
that I really like about it is that it's
just like not ugly like a legal pad like
I love the look of legal pads but it
just doesn't really fit into my like
desk aesthetic setup Vibe thing
um I still have a bunch of them but for
small notes for coding and stuff like
this thing has been great when I write
out with any like regular pen the pages
don't bleed through it's also easy to
stick up pages I wrote on with some
washi tape somewhere if I need to like
make some mental notes or something and
I like using this as a blend between
like analog like writing in this and
then also writing in notion I do kind of
both digital and analog because they
serve different purposes for me and the
last thing that I want to talk about as
part of my desk setup are these new
speakers that I got this is the House of
Marley Get Together Duo and I gotta say
they're really elegant like the wood
grain of the bamboo is really pretty the
black accents are nice the sound really
performs quite wonderfully of course I
didn't get like a subwoofer so the bass
is not like
but I'm not trying to do that one I'm
working I'm just really listening to
some Lo-Fi to be honest what's really
cool about these speakers is that they
can connect to your computer or a
turntable or a phone using aux or like
those red and white audio cables but you
can also connect to them via Bluetooth
so you can connect to them and then put
them in different parts of the room and
then obviously you get surround sound
which I haven't used it like that yet
but it's really nice to have that
flexibility should I need it so that
kind of covers like my desk setup 2023
muigo is back as a software engineer and
this is what her desk looks like so I
hope you enjoyed this video I know I
haven't been posting very much but other
videos are coming about kind of like my
new life as a software engineer and
thoughts that I have so there's any
topics that you want me to cover any
questions that you have make sure to
leave them in the comments down below
and hey if you've gotten this far in the
video thank you so much for watching and
also thank you for coming back to my
channel even though it's been a long
time since I posted like really
appreciate it thanks for being here as
always don't forget to subscribe to my
channel and I will see you next time bye
[Music]
foreign